so I read last week that the mayor of
Madrid uh wants to ban all protest in
the center of the Spanish Capital uh
anyone it was traveled to Spain in
recent years has come across protesters
in public places like the pla de
catalunia in
Barcelona where as you see here uh where
a village sprang up after the Spanish
economy collapsed akin to the one in New
York sucat Park last month tens of
thousands of demonstrators took over uh
cologne Square in Madrid rallying uh
against continuing unemployment and EU
related austerity measures and then
during the night some protesters clashed
with police so the mayor who earlier
this year cracked down on buskers
provoking a wave of populist outrage and
mockery on YouTube petitioned the
national government to prevent all
gatherings in central Madrid at a time
when the city needs to attract tourism
and investment she said demonstrations
quote undermine the city's
image I would say the reverse is true
they prove the vitality and resilience
of the Spanish in any case we see the
unfolding consequences of occupation in
Kev where demonstrators took over
Independence Square and the
reverberations from taher uh now include
the death sentences handed down by a
judge in March uh on 529 Egyptians
associated with the deposed Muslim
Brotherhood uh who were accused of
attacking a police station in Mina where
uh an officer was killed last
August and there we are in t here as for
Istanbul uh last Summer's occupation of
gazi Park in toxim square as Gary said I
went to watch it um and the Crackdown by
government forces emboldened opponents
of prime minister eredan to pursue
corruption charges against him in
response erdoan last month blocked
Twitter and YouTube to prevent the
sharing of what he has called false
allegations of corruption and
wrongdoing local elections just the
other day a couple days ago uh provided
a vote of confidence for erdan who used
Victory to threaten Mass arrests of
detractors and encouraged his enemies to
flee the country clearly the Protestant
GUI had a point about threatened
freedoms erdan speaks for turkey's
religious conservatives who constitute
roughly half maybe a little more than
half uh of the country many of whom felt
themselves marginalized under turkey's
secular rulers gzi like other public
spaces for protest became a kind of
Crucible for Dissent forging this
Alliance of diverse opponents Urban
intellectuals secular-minded Turks
nationalists all of whom in a sense
discovered each other and their shared
grievances on the common ground of the
Park I want to unpack some Notions about
public space today its design and uses a
topic of widespread discussion lately I
will first state the obvious about the
body politic then when we talk about the
politics of public space we are talking
both about space and bodies about the
physical presence of bodies occupying
space which is inseparable from and
constantly reformed by the interactions
of those bodies spaces are not fixed
they constantly change I want to look at
specific public spaces occupied by
protesters like zucati and GUI but then
to broaden the discussion to include
public space more generally because when
we talk about politics and public space
we miss the point if we limit ourselves
to sites of protest so my main focus
will turn to projects in Egypt Venezuela
and the West
Bank asked about the deaths of Migrant
workers uh constructing a stadium in
Qatar
about
832 nepales and Indian workers uh have
been killed so far working on World Cup
construction
sites um a well-known architect uh was
recently quoted as saying I have nothing
to do with the workers it is not my duty
as an architect to look at it um her
partner then denounced quote moralizing
political
correctness saying it quote is trying to
paralyze us with bad conscience and our
Explorations if we cannot demonstrate a
manifest tangible benefit to the poor as
if the delivery of social justice is the
architect's
competency so I Ser added earlier that
the spaces we design are shaped not just
by the bodies that use them but also the
ones that build
them and I'm grateful for these
unfortunate remarks by The Architects
because they help to accelerate a timely
conversation there's a dialectic
undercurrent that runs throughout this
talk between design and adaptation
intention and improvisation control and
formlessness engagement and
isolation Architects don't act alone but
neither must they be passive and I see
here a rich and promising vein for
architects today who want to reclaim
architecture's place at the
decision-making table to return it to
the center of discussions about how we
live and who we wish to be as a society
and not only make formally and
materially P in
buildings clearly we can't say that
protesters taking to the streets or
taking over public space is anything new
I'm sorry those the migrant
workers this is
Prague it's nothing new but awareness of
urban public space has grown Awareness
on a governmental as well as a populace
level of its meaning and use in a
Democratic Society of the relationship
of design to issues like public health
safety social equity and civic identity
the relationship is asynchronous but
determinative between demands for public
space and for democracy when we talk
about politics and public space we
should begin with the given that
Politics as Judith Butler has put it
already exists quote in the home or on
the street or in the neighborhood or
indeed in those virtual spaces that are
equally Unbound by the architecture of
the house and the
square close quote officials Architects
and planners design public space to
serve certain functions or prevent
others this is itself a political act I
show you here a design for Ground Zero
uh the new World Trade Center that's how
you will be able to drive in and out of
the new supposedly open streets that
have been created in the uh around the
new buildings at the World Trade Center
but then what happens when people use
the space is that other politics are
enact Ed it is this enactment by
changing configurations of bodies and
interests within the space that makes
architecture Inseparable from politics
space is a container but also a stage
for Action as Hanah aens said political
action requires a space of appearance
and a true polus is quote the
organization of the people as it arises
out of acting and speaking together that
is a polus expresses itself through the
interaction of people in a place
it is at once the place and the people
she added quote its true space lies
between people living together for this
purpose so politics you might say happen
more specifically in the spaces between
us which concentrate in public space as
I said about GUI public spaces make
visible to the world people who might
otherwise remain visible invisible to
each other but to gain attention the act
of occupation requires disrupting spaces
designed and maintained for other
purposes this is a picture of zucati and
you can see in it the uh various um
areas that were set aside it looks
chaotic but there's a tent area there's
a media area there's a
library none of which of course were
authorized by the people who designed
the
park this challenges Authority public
space functioning as both the object of
that challenge and the instrument of
protests the challenge may be as benign
as sleeping in a square or holding up a
banner whatever it is it questions
territoriality territory is not ground
or torrain nor is it a given Sask
assassin has written it is a complex
capability with embedded Logics of power
and
Reclamation so for sassin protests like
the ones in taher square or zuka Park
cast into doubt what she calls the
larger quote binary of national versus
global by which modernity has formul
ated its political structures quote to
occupy these spaces she writes is to
remake their territoriality and thereby
their embedded Logics of Power by
introducing Logics of sharing and
solidarity so occupation redefines a
space whose underlying logic it
interrogates bodies and space together
crucially this combination implies
physical sacrifice and risk today the
media including social media broadcast
protested in real time around the world
the 24-hour news cycle Facebook Twitter
feed the global Public's appetite for
drama and the expectation of bearing
witness to anything and everything
instantly from a safe
distance Facebook and Twitter can call
people to arms and like telephones I'm
sorry television and smartphones keep an
eye on what's Happening so that
authorities may think twice about
cracking down violently on protesters
it's not a coincidence that Turkish
police who fired tear gas in gzi
park were for a while chastened by
worldwide broadcast critical of their
actions while in Turkish cities that
were off the media's radar where
protesters also gathered the PO the
police felt no such
constraints so there's a symbiotic
relationship protesters count on their
being witnessed remotely in Virtual
space but it is only real bodies in real
space that occupy a real physical site
which provid provides the necessary
drama of that occupation to quote Butler
again quote the media requires these
bodies on the street to have an event
even as those bodies on the street
require the media to exist in a global
Arena if this conjuncture of Street and
media constitutes a very contemporary
version of the public sphere then bodies
on the line have to be thought of as
both there and here now and then
transported and stationary with very
different political consequences for
following from these two modalities of
space and
time of course it also matters not just
that spaces be physically occupied but
which spaces are occupied and how which
buildings squares by how many people and
whom the protests in gzi taher the PLA
catalunia and at zuka Park share certain
Telltale traits this is the pla
catalunia all of these spaces were the
consequence of urban modernization
programs all of them are spaces
surrounded by buildings all are
contained and concentrated but porous
spaces taher and the plaza de catalunia
are traffic hubs um Taha really is a
traffic circle and the plaza has a park
as you see here at its Center but
there's enormous amount of bus and other
traffic that runs around
it and the pla has a park at its Center
as I said a condition akin to gazi which
is a scruffy little park within toxic
Square itself enclosed by streets and uh
mostly modern hotels and other
buildings I'm sorry this slide is so
hard to read but this is this is
gazi and this is the square itself of
toxim and we'll get back to this but
this is what erdan planned to rec this
is the original ottoman Barracks that
was on the site of gazi and here's the
plan he had for tearing down GUI and
replacing it with new uh uh a basically
a shopping mall that would have been in
the form of the old Ottoman
Barracks so let's focus though on
zucati um it's a theater in the round
effect it's it's a mostly concrete
rectangular Plaza uh typically used by
office workers to eat lunch bounded by
streets and tall buildings so uh here
you see Broadway on this side Trinity
Street Cedar and Liberty and so the
streets roll around and here are the big
buildings on either side I'll show you a
map in a
moment maybe many of you know it um and
uh so it's bounded as I said and it
means that a few hundred people can make
it look crowded and more people can
watch it or watch what's happening
inside it from both uh the sidelines and
above it was not until 2011 a site for
protesters there are hundreds of rallies
and protests in New York every year I
found out last week that the parks
department issued some 200 150 permits
for rallies and vigils last year most of
them for dog hammerhal plaza near the UN
or Union Square Washington Square Park
uh Thomas Payne plaza near the federal
courts as well zucati was a kind of
serendipitous Choice protesters had
wanted to Occupy Wall Street but the
police prevented them so they set up
camp three blocks north in a park next
door to the World Trade Center site I'm
sorry let me go back to this just to
point
out this this is a kind of map of the
layout of where how the protesters um uh
arranged the park rearranged the park
for their occupation may I just ask how
many people were at zucati or saw the
site so a fair number um but there were
all these areas of food uh
delivery really free food Media Center
as was called Library much of the uh
observing crowd was here the World Trade
Center is going to be that
way I'll get back to that issue in a
moment um and just to show you again so
here if I can find it here's zucati
here's Wall Street so they went two
blocks north this is the World Trade
site right here so it's around the
corner from those
two um and this was not a public park
but one of the city's so-called
privately owned public space basis us
steel the original owner built the park
in 1968 in return for the right to add
additional floors to its office building
on the north side of the park a Citywide
program created similar quasi public
Spaces by granting private developers
exemptions to zoning restrictions mostly
developers created Barron plazas which
we all know in return for these bonuses
purposely undesirable and poorly
maintained because they didn't actually
want anybody to gather in front of their
buildings zucati a step up design-wise
from the earliest plazas was originally
called Liberty Plaza Park and it became
a popular spot in warm weather after an
$8 million renovation following 911 when
it was renamed zucati park by its new
owner Brookfield
properties precisely because the park
and here you see it on a normal day
because because the park was not public
it was not subject to the rules that
govern public parks
like the prohibition against sleeping
overnight I just want to show you here I
took a photograph of this um not so long
ago this was the original um sign that
told you what you could not do in zucati
park and this was why people could
settle in zucati park these are the
things you couldn't do you couldn't
roller skate you couldn't skateboard
roller skate or
bicycle that's a short list this is now
a list of the things you can no longer
do in zucati park it's small print so I
always have to read the small print and
suffice it to say you can't put up a
tent you can't lie down you can't sit
for a long period of time you can't put
your bags down unless you they're right
here they can't block anything in other
words you can't sit in zti park anymore
in stage of
protest so but because it had not had
those restrictions it was of course a
place paradoxically that people could
occupy unlike a public park which closes
at night so it became in a sense
occupied site by default the irony that
occupy could only occupy a public space
because it actually took over a private
one built by us steel and then owned by
a big commercial real estate company NS
this was lost on no one but just as
important was how that space was
occupied its renovation a decade ago
added these trees and seeding which
you've seen which provided cover and
divided the space up in ways the
protesters
capitalized on imagine zucati Park one
protester told me as the intersecting
point on a ven diagram of characters
representing disperate political and
economic
disenchantments and I don't think it's
coincidental that these strangers who
came together at sucat as well as in
gizi and elsewhere all formed popup
towns on these sites in producing a kind
of bite-sized form so long as they
lasted of what they imagined to be the
outlines of a larger Equitable City with
separate spaces for free food legal
service serves libraries medical
stations and so forth Aristotle talked
about the ideal polus extending the
distance of a Herald's cry a space in
which people communicated face to
face couldn't resist sorry here again
the politicized shifting space between
bodies and it was meaningful that
sukarti using microphones to address the
crowd uh I'm sorry that in suukat um
being contained space um allow
protesters who were prevented by the
police from using microphones to address
the crowd uh repeated phrases phrase by
phrase um that the speakers uh at the
park um uttered so that speeches um
could be heard farther away so as it
were everyone spoke in one voice playing
this game of
telephone the same crowd of course would
have looked very puny in Central Park
and there would have been no one around
to notice it similarly guy Park had not
been
on um many people's radar uh before it's
a kind of shambolic modestly used Green
Space popular for yoga classes and
sleeping off a hard night in toxin
squares um that was beforehand but it
turned out to be like zukar a meaningful
site it's on the edge of toxim which is
a very fluid irregular open
unpredictable Place reflecting the
area's historic identity at the heart of
modern Multicultural turkey
this was where poor European immigrants
settled during the 19th century it was a
honky Tong quarter during the 1980s a
Haven to gays and lesbians a locust for
nightclubs foreign movie palaces and
French style covered arcades this a
university nearby it's where young
people and tourists congregate at
night gravestones from an Armenian
Cemetery toxin were said to have been
demolished in
1939 and used to construct stairs at GUI
which was a republican era project by
the French planner orri PR that brought
modernism to Istanbul's heart and into
the urban fabric as it did the jumble of
high-rise hotels and the now shuddered
opera house that surround the park all
this of course was precisely what prime
minister erdan didn't like and he
triggered the protest by threatening to
demolish and then remake toxim as a Neo
aom and theme park that's a slightly
clearer version of what I saying before
getting rid of
and undoing what several Turks describe
to me as their quote unruly Commons in
the middle of the
city never mind that there's precious
little public green space in the center
of Istanbul the fact that GUI was an
informal and unpredictable Place made it
suspicious to erdan and a natural center
of gravity for
protesters as atsuka its compact design
surrounded by streets with shabby alyss
and walkways dividing modest Lawns and
disused fountains
turned out to be readymade for the
hodgepodge of services encampments
gardening efforts and food stalls that
divied up the occupation site there was
some creative use made of cheap
materials to provide specific areas for
picnic tables exhibition spaces and
something called the Revolutionary
Museum a popup gallery that chronicled
the history of Turkish protests
providing the protesters with instant
bonafides one Turk told me Turkish
people who have taken over gzi Park in
protest feel it is truly theirs not
something awarded to them by their
leaders this is critical I think the
notion of top down versus bottom up
public space spaces people are given and
passively use versus spaces they remake
for
themselves I want to turn from
occupation because we need to Define
public space more broadly it is not just
an area of protest it encompasses the
entirety of the public realm that we
build and politics are are no less
present when this realm constitutes
sidewalks Transit stations streets
highways bike paths and playgrounds
where daily life happens in
public our very definition of public of
democracy is tested by the distribution
design and use of these spaces who
controls these spaces shapes them and
what do their physical properties say
about us this by the way is a view of um
the Plaza uh at Madison Square Park in
New York and I'll just I'll just
interrupt myself to tell you very
briefly it's an interesting place it's
where Fifth Avenue in Broadway across as
you may remember around 23rd Street and
there's Madison Square Park and then
there are these um triangles there's a
triangle created by that um
Crossing and um one of the early things
that the Bloomberg Administration
transportation department proposed was
to uh turn that triangle and part of the
Crossing in much of Broadway into a
pedestrian
Plaza and Michael beut who's a
extraordinary designer for firm called
pentagram has his office right there and
even he said this is completely insane I
mean you have one of the most beautiful
parks in the city who in the world is
going to want to
sit in the middle of the street you're
taking over the middle of the street and
why were they going to sit in the street
when they can just go sit in the park
this is crazy and of course this has
turned out to be one of the great urban
renewal uh projects in in
Manhattan why do people want to sit in
the street because one wants because
being in a park is a different thing
than being in a plaza right a park is an
enclosed space usually you go into it
Plaza is continuous usually with the
rest of the city and people want to be
in the plaza because they want to be in
the middle of things they want to be in
the middle of the street where they can
have views of the Empire State Building
and the flat iron building and where
there's a lot of things happening and it
turns out that we can reclaim these
spaces where people used to actually
move a lot more freely uh before they
were given over to cars uh if we look at
the street as another kind of public
space and not just the space taken over
by cors anyway this is one of this is
one of the plaas that are at Madison
Square uh that's been
converted a very a very definition of
public of democracy I think is tested by
the distribution design and use of these
spaces who controls these spaces shapes
them and what do their physical
properties say about us such questions
have been of course at the heart of this
larger critique of neoliberal values
whose bankruptsy provoked the market
collapse that helped Inspire the Occupy
Movement the 1% is epitomized these days
by the 90 million apartments in uh the
skyscrapers around uh now Rising around
New York's most cherished public site um
Central Park leveraging views of that
Park while casting Shadows onto it and
on the people who use it this is a
picture of um what's called 157 it's the
first of what are going to be many uh
extremely tall luxury towers that are
rising around 57th Street um this will
be the puniest of them it's it's a th000
feet tall most of the others are about
14 to 1500 feet tall um so as tall as
the World Trade um Cent One World Trade
Center um and somehow some crazy people
actually paid $90 million to get the pen
houses in this spectacularly ugly
building um which is a mystery to almost
everybody but there you are wealth has
its own ways and these are some of the
buildings that will rise around Central
Park um just to give you an idea of
what uh of what has happened to uh
development in the city partly for
reasons that are technological the
ability to uh create very slender
buildings which uh with um elevators and
stairs that can take up very little
space and get people very quickly uh up
to the tops of these buildings um the
zoning rules I I don't want to get too
bogged down in the weeds here but it is
kind of interesting the relationship of
architecture zoning and Public Health in
that um the basically these buildings
have happened and as of right that is
without having to get even City approval
because developers had bought a lot of
different related plots added up the air
rights from all of them which you can do
and created this extra tall building
well nobody imagined you would be able
to create a building that was 1500 feet
high with one apartment on each floor
because it would have made no economic
sense unless you have what has happened
now in our neoliberal culture that you
have people who are perfectly happy to
pay $100 million for an apartment so the
economy has made that possible and then
the technology of the buildings and the
engineering of the buildings has
conspired to make that possible so
that's what's happening I think it's
interesting because it as I said
Leverage is a public space Central Park
which is what they're essentially
selling in these properties The View
over the park 57 Street as you know is
not in itself a fantastically wonderful
place to
live and I think the privileging of
private property the reshuffling of
public resources to accommodate this
private wealth these kind of neoliberal
shibs cast a spotlight on public space
even a generation or two ago Richard
senet noted the Assumption was a quote
the Assumption was not why made that
streets were public space it was space
you moved through and only poor people
dwelt in the street Richard says I don't
think that's quite true but we
overestimate the perspective of Jane
Jacobs who extrapolated theories about
design and public space from living in
the West
Village that's Jane Jacobs riding on a
bicycle uh where I happened to grow up
in the West Village The Village was not
like most Urban neighborhoods Senate
reminded me the other day uh that luchow
the famous German restaurant on Union
Square during the middle of the last
century added an open a cafe but mayor
LaGuardia shut it down as an affront to
public morals a cafe encouraged men and
women to loiter in the street it was
determined and only the destitute and
depraved loitered in the street luch
house closed in the 1980s pretty much
because nobody went to Union Square any
longer it had become so blighted the
romance of New Yorkers hanging out on
their Stoops children playing stick ball
and running through the showers from
open fire hydrants belies the fact that
while there were great hubs of street
life on the lower side and in Time
Square and elsewhere streets were on the
whole corridors and not where the middle
class dwell they were not public spaces
as we now think of public space public
spaces were
Parks handed down by authorities like
Robert Moses who created nearly 800 of
them in New York today we would regard
marara Moses's Park program as socialist
it was the contribution of sociologists
like William white to show how people
might wish to use parks and streets and
sidewalks to index what makes them
friendly and attractive Urban
places this is not William white but a
man in Brian
Park and this is Brian Park
now it took decades to Institute the
necessary improvements some of them
financed by public private Partnerships
like the park in a sense the cityan
public caught up with Jacob's white and
their concepts of a healthy public realm
just in time for people to realize how
public space was being compromised and
cooperated by the neoliberal ruling
class occupied by powerful agencies
focusing on security and surveillance
and by private interest exploiting the
public nest of public space for profit
and
advertisement I I would only say about
the Koch theater that um uh this was
very generous gift of $100 million from
David kooch but the State Theater had
been created specifically with the idea
that it was a um it was a gift of the
New Yorker the New York State citizens
to themselves and so was called the New
York State Theater from the
beginning and Mr K is also financing uh
paid the $65 million to create the coke
Plaza um in front of the Metropolitan
Museum which will open
soon pretty much outside his
window this gets to the heart of agency
and
Authority some of the most intriguing
examples
of there he is again with his wife
that's
the construction site some of the most
intriguing examples of political action
in public space aren't protests per se
but the reconfiguration of public Spaces
by people Architects and urban designers
included who have taken matters matters
into their own hands officially or
otherwise the first example involves an
addition to the Ring Road in Cairo made
by residents of Ard aliwa a neighborhood
bordering that
Highway and here you see the Ring Road
as it sort of winds through cairo's
sprawl the highway uh is a project of
Mubarak hos Mubarak and part of cairo's
disastrous exurbanization which has
insulated many wealthy Egyptians Behind
the Walls of gated community ities on
the city's outskirts the proliferation
of gated communities is a global
phenomenon perhaps the most disturbing
Urban Trend today cities are exploding
around the world as we all know but many
of them in Latin America India and China
are modeling themselves not after places
like Boston or New York or Berlin they
are mimicking American style gated
communities the antithesis of healthy
Urban growth the Gated residence has
become the housing complex of choice in
much much of the developing world its
effects in terms of open space you might
say are akin to uh the enclosures of
agricultural Lander the 17th century
which did away with the commons the
trend is accelerating and you see its
effects in Cairo this
is um a place called uh kmia Heights
which I went to see and um they they you
have these gated residents with golf
courses built that's camia Heights built
smack in the middle of the
desert um Mubarak panding pandering to
the elite focused on highways and sprawl
to encourage these developments ignoring
public transit and public spaces and in
addition to the Ring Road he
commissioned the sixth of October bridge
and Causeway linking taher Square
Downtown commercial area with affluent
suburbs like nazer City and New Cairo in
a country where only 14% of the
population owns cars and where more than
20 20 million people have almost no
green space Mubarak envisioned modern
Cairo as a middle eastern version
essentially of post-war America with
freeways
Automobiles and class Exodus from a
festering city center so it was natural
that the 6th of October Bridge became a
site of violent clashes between
protesters and government forces During
the Revolution but something even more
dramatic I think happened after
mubarak's fall and during the Purgatory
you might say of morsey's aborted rule
post Revolution Kines whose
neighborhoods had been ignored by
Mubarak and bypassed by his highways
constructed their own public spaces in
mbebe a neighborhood sometimes nicknamed
the Islamic Republic of mbebe with a
population larger than Manhattan
residents formed popular committees
neighborhood coalitions and these
committees pulled resources to fix roads
that were untended organized trash
collection enhan public squares and
police the streets
this is actually a neighborhood
committee taking over an area in vbe May
alashi an Egyptian architect with whom I
spoke about um Guerilla urbanism in
Cairo this was before the military
takeover told me what's definitely
changed is that before in Cairo someone
always used to dictate where you were
allowed to sit and walk what you were
allowed to do or say this new right to
express yourself in the street is not
mind
or a luxury the street was not really
public space now it
is and I saw this nowhere more clearly
Illustrated than on the Ring Road which
was built specifically to bypass and
thereby isolate Ard aliwa which like in
Bebe is an immense informal settlement
for years workers including government
workers living there in in
ardala had to waste hours every day
getting to jobs Downtown because they
couldn't take the road so in the absence
of either help or interference by
morsey's government residents
constructed their own on and off ramps
to the
highway they built these ramps out of
dirt sand and trash and then they
invited the police to open a kiosk at
The Interchange which the police did it
was fullon do-it-yourself infrastructure
a massive assertion of genuine Public
Authority over public space and of
course an implicit rejection of
exclusionary Politics as Omar nagati
also an Egyptian architect and planner
put it to me this was again before the
military takeover this was always a
revolution he said about unjust Urban
conditions and about public space the
ramp is just one example people realized
they had to determine what happens on
their own streets to their own
neighborhoods so he said they erupted a
battle of ownership throughout Egypt
over whose space the this is and who
determines whose space it
is that's also what uh has happened in
kakas with the Tor David an unfinished
and abandoned 45 story office building
from the early 1990s in the former
Central business district of the city
which has famously become the Imp the
improvised home for more than 750
families those of you who are architects
in the room might know of this they've
created in effect a vertical squat
a team of Architects based in surich
which calls itself Urban Think Tank has
been studying the tower for years and
sees in it the enormous potential for
experimentation and creative reuse that
characterizes most informal settlements
I would say this is
true residents of the David Tower have
created essentially a mixed use
development um with electricity a kind
of rube gold bergian water system uh
security uh grocery stores office supply
stores hairdressers
tailor
um a uh basketball court uh with teams
that play in local
leagues um a gym and an Evangelical
Church around which the building's uh
centralized system of governance has
arisen what had been an adhawk
adaptation to a site has increasingly
become regulated redesign Squad ERS use
brick tiles and other found materials to
demarcate apartments and
rooms um bringing really vernacular
styles of uh arched doorways interior
windows and neocolonial architecture all
sorts of uh things that they have seen
elsewhere to uh often in the baros but
bringing this to a glass and concrete uh
unfinished modern office
tower this adaptive
reuse reclaiming what is a kind of
disused public space is um a microcosm
of the mega City itself is urban think
Tech points out um as a site for
reordering the social metric the
residents unencumbered by principles of
design this is a quote by German Think
Tank theories of Aesthetics or the
received wisdom of the past build what
makes sense to them they go on to uh say
if this is the future if Tory deid is
the informal City writ small architect
and urban planners face a major
challenge who and what are we to those
we serve what exactly are we designing
and to what end that's all Urban think
tank and the group partly tries to
answer that question by proposing to put
wind turbines on top of the tower and
create a kind of pulley system that
would cheaply transport goods and people
up and down a tall uh shaft in the
absence of elevators because there are
no working elevators in the building but
there's a more I think evolved answer in
the form of a project for a refugee camp
in faad in the southern West Bank and I
will end with this example and then I'm
very anxious and happy to take any
questions and
comments two architects alesandro petti
and Sandy hillal worked with residents
of the faad camp to create a public
Plaza virtually unheard of in such
places and especially problematic among
Palestinian refugees For Whom the
creation of any permanent ity by
establishing normaly undermines their
fundamental self-image as temporary
occupants with the right of return to
homes in Israel we see from this and
everything else I've mentioned today the
notion of being in public is a
behavioral not just a spatial condition
which nonetheless depends on certain
spatial aspects in refugee camps public
and private do not exist conceptually as
they do elsewhere property is neither
public nor private in the camps refugees
do not own their
homes uh nor are streets Municipal
properties as they are in cities because
refugees are not citizens and the camp
is not a city the legal notion of the
refugee camp according to the United
Nations is in effect a temporary deite
for displaced stateless individuals not
a Civic body there is no municipality to
care for lights and garbage other things
and Concepts like inside and outside are
blurred in a place like faad a mother
may not wear the veil in the camp
whether she's at home or out on the
street but she will wear it when she
leaves the camp which is outside so
there is a powerful sense of
community and six years ago pety and
Halal began a conversation with
residents about creating a public Plaza
or Square the residents were suspicious
not just about normalizing the camp but
about about creating a space where men
and women might come together in
public Petty and hillal consulted groups
of women and pet has described the
discussions as two-way not just
Architects passively listening to what
the women said but themselves trying to
Envision what the women might want and
what everyone could use the question was
how to make a space that could be open
so that men and women would gather
together while allowing the women some
enclosure they didn't want to feel
exposed where they might be criticized
or made uncomfortable the plaza needed a
filter clearly an edge so was decided
that the space a site of about 50 by 100
m where there were three disused
shelters from the 1950s that needed to
be removed anyway that it was decided
they should not be completely
open a wall was devised The Architects
interviewed residents whose homes faced
the plaza site and negotiated with each
one separately the permeability of the
the wall in front of their houses so the
surrounding wall is here but where it
meets some of the houses um each
resident could say how open or closed
they wanted the wall to be to face the
plaza at a cost of about $300,000 for
Demolition and construction um the uh
The Architects created this Limestone
Plaza with stones uh with stone and
brick walls um I should say the cost was
high and the material of uh using Stone
was used because the residents also
became very much committed to creating
something that really looked um
permanent and that was unlike the rest
of the camp some place that spoke to
them spoke to their
aspirations um and to their Ambitions uh
for uh the community so more money was
um found and spent to create something
that looked uh better but in effect what
was created was a house without a roof
and this was to address the women's
problems the idea of a house without a
roof redefines public space as a space
for Collective privacy and
ownership the plaza is Akin in a sense
to the camp in making ambiguous the
distinction between inside and outside
women use it without being criticized
now for not being home the site is fost
uh various activities meetings children
play there um it's a refuge from the
overcrowded streets I don't think one
can uh underestimate what this means to
get off the streets of the refugee camps
and find a place of uh to to gather
that's not in one's own
home an older resident of faad recalling
a former life in cities where
Palestinian culture happened outside has
said we didn't have any adequate space
where we could sit without feeling that
we were basically sitting in the streets
and blocking traffic I think that the
plaza is giving us the possibility to
recreate our culture of using outside
spaces we can design public spaces that
represent us in our diversity can we
design spaces specifically for protest I
don't think so and what does protest
yield Egypt has become a military
dictatorship I think it's maybe still
too early to say that taher had no
impact since democratic reol tions are
messy require generations to play out
occupy had the effect of making Concepts
like the 1% part of everyday speech
which instantly contributed to Mayor
Bill deblasio's election Victory with
its Tale of Two Cities I suspect most
politicians and private developers took
away from the Occupy Movement that in
future they need to work harder to
design spaces that can't be occupied but
I think another lesson is that millions
of people dream of opportunity and
equality
and that those dreams will continue to
be contested and expressed in the public
spaces we build for each other and for
ourselves thanks very
much
thanks you started out with with an
architect saying very gloomy things
about about the responsibility of
Architects you ended with with the zor
group saying the opposite and and I'm
wondering yeah what is the play of of of
the architects who stand behind the
development specifically in New York
City of this these extraordinary kind of
as you said neoliberal kind of
spectacles of these huge Towers is there
is there any sense of this
responsibility coming to coming to Roost
coming home to roost in the United
States yeah you know I should say very
clearly at the beginning that you know
obviously Architects don't they're not
responsible
for um everything and uh and Architects
also you know we we need I I didn't mean
to suggest that we don't need luxury
apartment buildings or or places for uh
people to um uh places of beauty and uh
or stadiums or Arenas or whatever um I
think it's a complicated problem because
I think a lot of it has to do with the
question of um that's now risen I think
more acutely within the architectural
Community how how do archit what is the
responsibility of Architects and how is
that how is their role um uh
legislated um it's my impression that
architects in a certain sense sacrific
some of the um uh responsibility that
they had years ago partly because there
was a public reaction against
um uh certain kinds of urban plans and
uh the 50s the sort of whole the
reimagining of of cities and suburbs
that uh essentially limited Architects
roles they you know they have a they
have their fee and they do their thing
and for litigation reasons as well it
doesn't extend beyond that so I mean I
think there are a lot of things going on
I think there's a conversation taking
place within the world of architecture
that has a lot to do with as it should
about formal and material possibilities
um but I also think that it's uh is
incumbent upon Architects to um discuss
the question of how they fun function
within the society they are helping to
create to see these buildings as I tried
to say here these buildings as spaces as
not simply objects but as places that
are affected by and affect the people
who use them and um I think this is an
this needs to evolve because there my
impression I'm not an architect my
impression is that there's a still a
kind of
um opposition created a false opposition
created between those people who want to
become sah Hadid and get to design fancy
big buildings like this uh and those
people who sort of say they want to do
good works and the people who do the one
kind of think that the people doing the
other aren't really doing
architecture and the people doing this
um I think also feel somehow that they
are not uh respected by the people doing
architecture that that I think that's an
evolving conversation I think that will
change some of it I see as my own one
small role and that is where the
spotlight turns tends to be where um
money power and interests congregate so
if you only focus on one kind of
architectural project then um and if
that happens to be the sort of tow as
you're describing then those will um
continue to be things that people will
think are rewarded um let me just say
one other thing about the 57 Street
developments I mean I think
um
I think it's a good question whether
architects involved in these projects um
uh are should I I think the Architects
need to be able to answer questions uh
like how does that building what is the
what is the payoff for the public at
large for that building um what you know
what what is the building demanding of
the city around it and what is it giving
in return there there are different ways
that can be answered and some of those
can be answered by the beauty of the
building um but the architect should
have answers to those questions even if
they're not originally responsible
otherwise I can't imagine taking on such
a project and one of the issues that
comes up in relation to that is uh if
you're demanding space um that is very
conspicuous on the skyline then in a
certain sense you're you're not just
taking up the space that you occupy or
even the space casting a shadow but the
a larger space in the in the city itself
and there are cities uh like London um
which do consider view corridors and the
ways in which we
protect
uh the The View I mean this is going to
create I when I wrote about these I
mentioned this it's sort of like a chess
board in which the original buildings
along Central Park South are the ponds
but now these giant buildings will rise
be Beyond it and that does change the
city
itself um so I you know I mean I think
there a lot of issues that relate to the
public responsibility here which at
least Architects should begin to try to
answer and some of the ones who work in
those projects of course do have answers
for
that yeah
Peggy as an architect I actually would
love to continue that conversation
because I think it's
complicated it's not my question but let
me just do I I do think that Architects
tend to think that they're getting the
scraps um that they're not players at
the table to make those choices and
we're just trying to get any work
whatsoever and it happens to be really
tall and really
big great but but and I'm not trying to
in any way justify that but I think it
it feels we feel disempowered and hence
not at the table for that kind of
discussion we should be but let me just
inter up to say to clarify this so I I
of course this is this is true but the
projects that I mentioned like the ones
that they're doing in in the West Bank
and we could think of others like um you
know Mass doing the pro the hospital
project in uh I mean there there there
are ways in which Architects can take
can get to the table by taking an
initiative and taking on projects that
you can't just create a project that's
aund you know 1500 Story Tower in 57
street but you can create other projects
depends on what kind of projects you're
talking about right yeah and it really
does mean looking for the work you want
to do as opposed to the work that's
handed to you absolutely um the question
that I did want to ask uh had to do with
uh your emphasis on public spaces being
um our right and not something that is a
gift that's handed to us um and I think
that lingered in your conversation about
streets too in particularly in Cairo
that um that in some way when they took
back the streets or found public space
that it wasn't just that they were
taking something that hadn't been theirs
but originally had been theirs and it
was it was their right to reclaim it in
some way so I'm curious to know for all
the different places that you've been
whether one whether you feel confident
to say that that is a condition of
streets and and public spaces or whether
the particular economic historical
cultural conditions actually does vary
such that one would have to modify that
claim or that those modifications don't
help the yeah no I mean I think I look I
I do think it varies from place to place
um and I guess what I was trying to
suggest was that even the notion of the
street as a public space in a place like
New York is a relatively recent concept
um I mean it's a I'm not I wasn't quite
sure I thought somebody might mentioned
this I wasn't quite sure of this but I
think it is true that not so long ago
people didn't really think of the
streets as public space it's it's a
little complicated because if you look
back let's say at a photograph of New
York City in 1908 what you'll see are
very wide sidewalks and a kind of
Continuum between the street and the
sidewalk because you had street cars you
didn't have many um uh automobiles yet
and so there was a feeling that the
whole Space was kind of pedestrian
friendly now did people consider the
street public space as we do now I don't
know about that I think that's a
slightly different thing I think what we
are developing is this sense um and this
is what I was trying to get at that
there is this relationship between the
space and the the the Democracy the
formation of physical space and the the
Declaration demand of of democratic
space that I
don't I don't think it's been the the
the discourse for a very long period
perod of time but of course you know um
I can't say that that's the the case
everywhere what I can say though is that
it's probably not coincidental that when
protests have happened they continue to
happen in public spaces I mean I think
there is an instinctive feeling that
people need to find this common ground
and whether they Define it as public
space and the demands for public space
are related to their own Ambitions or
not they somehow understand that the
only place where these these issues
really are clarified or somehow made
physical is in these things called
public spaces does that does that make
sense
yeah but I mean certainly not you know
the way people think in Bahrain is
different than the way they think in
Copenhagen I mean there's no I think
there's no yeah I gu think about the
commends right see I don't think there
is a notion of the Commons in bah but I
do think there were protests and they
sought what is in effect the closest
they've got to a Commons to Stage it
there which didn't work partly because
it was a space that was too easily um it
wasn't the same sort of enclosed stage
like space it was a space much too
easily taken back from them um there
really aren't in many of the Gulf States
spaces that where you can congregate and
that's on purpose I think yeah thanks
for a great talk um I really was
interested in your idea of how the
spaces are misused right none of them
were designed for protests and it
doesn't seem likely that we're going to
see you know a bunch of spaces starting
to be designed for protest in upcoming
years I don't know that the Architects
will ever be hired by the protesters by
the people right so it seems like it'll
always be uh this sort of sense of
misinterpretation or misuse uh that's
really essential and um anyway I just
wanted to mention something I was part
of occupy Oakland and you know was the
most militant of the occupi movements
but also the most Innovative and you
know everyone only heard about our riots
but that was one of only like three
branches of what was going on there
there were like the mainstream sort of
liberals who believed that we just
needed to tweak our democracy and
they're there to sort of speak to power
hoping they'd be heard that was the
first uh the second was the riers that
you heard which were like the most
extreme and they they were very much
there for another version of declarative
politics and then there's this sort of
third group of people who were
interested in self- valorization so like
it seems like the city uh is usually
deployed as a way of creating capitalist
valorization and and there's this third
group of people who weren't interested
so much in confronting power or rioting
uh but as much as uh coming into like a
shared space and sharing right right and
and creating a second economy something
that was not necessarily capitalist and
I wonder if you've found anything like
that yeah no I mean I I was thank you
for that I was that's really what I was
trying to suggest in these in these kind
of pop-up towns that was that was almost
Universal which is in itself quite
interesting I mean even in GUI you know
people instantly set up these uh
as they're propositional uh
democracies um and you know in zcat it
was it I mean it itself became a problem
because they were giving away free food
and free clothing and then you know the
space essentially got taken over but I
think that's exactly what happened the
the people
enacted these spaces as they imagined a
better Society to be without really
there being a programmed to do that that
just seemed like the thing one needed to
do we need to by the space okay well how
do we go about doing that if we're going
to sleep here who's going to sleep where
who's in charge and suddenly you begin
to evolve this this space which is a
proposal of what they are talking about
because after all much of occupy was
unclear to people they I remember people
constantly saying but what is it
actually about what are they you know it
wasn't like against the war it wasn't
again you know it was what was the thing
and when you went to it you discovered
the thing was what you saw there the
thing was the the the the the creation
of this space that was what occupy um
Illustrated so I I agree with that and
about creating spaces of protest you
know I think as I said at the end I
don't I don't think it's possible I
think it has to do with any space can be
occupied um but I don't think um you can
really create a useful space of protest
erwan's trying to do it by the way he's
creating on the um Waterfront in the
South this sort of huge place for like
which you have a military parade or
something where if someone put a protest
it would be out of view and this is of
course crucial as well to these places
that they are in the middle um yeah
sorry uh really a followup on the last
comment but first a couple of
observations first of all for those of
us in the room not me who are not
Architects I want to uh uh say that what
you say so modestly about shining a
light in a a slightly different
direction really can't be underestimated
at this point in time I mean I think we
have seen the cumulative result of now
Decades of media attention to a certain
way of making space and buildings uh
that is far from a monolithic culture
but has been presented as if it was the
only culture that's valuable and I think
a lot of us have been very grateful for
uh again what you state relatively
modestly it really assumes enormous
importance in encouraging not maybe not
my generation but a Next Generation to
consider the possibilities that are out
there secondly just a historical note I
think there's a lot of evidence of the
kind of public space or at least the
signifiers of public space that you've
presented today going way way back in at
least in Western history when protesters
tear up the streets in early 19th
century Paris to make barricades right
um that is uh a conspicuous form of
occupation and of stating the public
availability of that space for alternate
ways of expressing power and there are
countless examples of that from parades
to feasts of fools in the Middle Ages
you name anyway abut uh but to the point
I I I think that what you have
introduced or suggested to me is that
space uh as a as a medium for uh
architecture and urbanism needs to also
always be balanced by time and I I I
wonder how you feel about that having
looked at these examples because most of
them appear in the way that you present
only after a certain period of time
right um and of course an architectural
contract not only has limits of
liability and responsibility in space
that are bounded by a legal legally
constituted site it also starts at a
certain point and stops at a certain
point and some of the most interesting
things that happen to what we design
happen well after our formal
relationship with them is brought to an
end so the notion that an architect can
be something like an organic
intellectual yeah and belong to a
community not just serve a community and
that an architect could be around to
look at the uses to which their spaces
are are are put is an important one the
most obvious example which you know very
well is uh the occupation of the lower
level of Norman Fosters uh Bank of Hong
Kong Hong Kong by uh domestics on their
off day in Hong Kong which he of course
never anticipated but which brings that
building to life in a way that he's
happy to take credit for I think exactly
uh so I I wonder what you think about
that and also about uh uh the the
implicit message in the last remarks
that that if you can uh in a way uh
learn from what happens in a space and
there is a feedback loop built into it
so that for example the explosion of
co-working spaces in American cities
after the Occupy Movement which modeled
that sort of Cooperative behavior is I
think another conspicuous example yeah
no you raised many interesting points
and um and in a way you answered some of
your own question I I think this issue
of remaining committed is very important
and it's totally outside the general
working model but it came up in um then
I'll get back to co-working spaces it
came up in an interesting way I was
looking at healthc care design and um I
which I still haven't gotten around to
write about but I really want to and the
reason was because I thought um in what
sense can you pin down in some specific
ways the um the effectiveness of design
can you quantify on some level
uh design is there any does that is that
a meaningful question to ask and is
there any area in which such a person
such a thing could be done by someone um
I when I wrote about VI the housing
project in the South Bronx I wanted to
change the equation of what we consider
to be uh value because I thought instead
of ter putting in terms of aesthetic
value look in terms of
investment um in the
community which is what architectural EX
was supposed to um contribute um so in
the case of hospital design I was struck
that uh you know there are people who
work on such things who who look at
design the effect of different kinds of
designs on on patient care and this is a
slightly long-winded answer but I'll
just say to you for instance in
Princeton there's a hospital which was
designing a new facility and so had a
model room in which they tested out
different designs
on different patients and refine the
design so that when they moved to the
new building they would have what they'
found to be the most effective design
and what they found over the course of
more than a year was that patients in
the model
room um asked for 45% less pain
medication and said that nursing care
and the food was 60% better than in the
other than in the normal rooms so this
was an interesting question and I asked
the guy who you know so what does this
mean about the effectiveness of design
and he said listen when we build these
hospitals I would like to have
Architects more involved but I would
like them to work on a contingency fee
like everybody else here so that they
follow up they do certain things and
they are then responsible for the
results of those things so if they build
something and say it's going to be I
want to know that the things that are
built here will be reduce infections
create happier and shorter hospital
stays for patients and so forth uh fewer
mistakes by you know nurses and doctors
and so if they can prove the few you
know spreading of infections that I said
if they
can produce results that are tangible I
will pay them more money I mentioned
this to a couple of people that are
architects in this room who are
Architects some of whom had worked on
these things and I thought to a person
Architects would say well that's the
most ridiculous thing I've ever heard
but actually I'm be interested to know
here to a person they said to me okay
that sounds kind of interesting if we
really have responsibility it's just
it's a slightly off answer to you but it
was a question of the extent to which
Architects can find ways to become more
engaged and I think they should be
responsible if you put up a building and
it doesn't work you should be
responsible if it may look beautiful but
if it doesn't work and I I could give
you a million Museum
examples you know then you should fix it
or somebody else should fix it as for
the um cooworker thing I just was out in
San Francisco and I'll just say to you I
spent a lot of time going to the new um
uh you know setups for people like
Twitter and Yelp and uh square and a lot
of these um it's it's pretty funny um
but their aesthetic this thing you're
talking about which arrives out of
occupy which has this kind of like we
are um here to make the world better and
we share stuff so you know there's a
barista always everywhere and there's
food and common tables and this too is
becoming
um really interestingly uh standardized
so everybody has Edison bulbs everybody
uses you know uh reclaimed railroad ties
they all look exactly alike they all
have the yoga ball they all have the
this is the you know so this has become
the kind of um version of so I I think
that's something that also is an
interesting question that that to really
create spaces that are uh truly open and
flexible and by the way they're very
um Grim places I mean they have this
whole cheery kind of stuff with sayings
on the walls you know about how their
community and and uh you know the
company is great it's it's really 1984
is but in fact it's very they're scary
places so I think it's an interesting
offshoot that you described but it's
already been kind of through design um
regularized yeah speaking rep railroad
ties um the notion that a might be
designed for protest I'm curious what
your opinions are in one in my opinion
one of the great n uh public parks
created recently the Highline yeah um
how unoccupied or occupiable is that as
a public space it's a linear Park in a
way it one might view that as a park
designed not to be
occupied as as a tra wait you're saying
you're Ser saying it's a space that
can't be occupied I I it perhaps in the
way uh for protest it might yeah I think
it would be a useless space to occupy
yeah I can't see why you would occupy it
first of
all uh no one would know you were there
I mean you're everyone's on the ground
and you're up there so and real New
Yorkers don't go to the Highline I mean
so life would go on and there'd be these
people up on the you know among these
very beautiful plantings with great
views into the hotel rooms of the you
know people at the standard and these
people paid millions of dollars so that
they could be seen walking around their
underpants in their Apartments but
otherwise no one would know you were
there so I think the Highline is not an
effective site um I mean in the sense
it's the opposite of zucati right zucati
was down and surrounded it was really
this stage in the round um but the
Highline is an interesting space of
course um to I mean I it's it's a
remarkable
achievement um at the same time it
really is not integrated into the City
and that gets to this point I'm perhaps
I'm saying what you're saying yeah yeah
the idea that perhaps there's conscious
uh conscious idea there to preserve it
as un occupiable for protest yeah I mean
I think that's maybe I don't know if
they recurred to them I think mostly
they were just trying to save it from
being destroyed and that was an
interesting gamble I don't know that
they imagined that it would be occupied
and now you know it's so crowded you
can't get up there any Who would know
you were even occupying it if you were
up there it's just you know it's just
too boots but it's but it's an
interesting point
yeah yeah oh I had a question about um
another um emerging public space you had
written about which is the public space
of a McDonald's or a Starbucks and
people just hanging out there for hours
and hours upon it and I was curious if
you is it in any way kind of like a
possibility in the future for that to be
sort of um I don't know encouraged or
something something similar to kind of
like the percent the the percent for art
thing percent for art or even with um
like plases and things like that yeah I
mean you mean to create coffee shop or
or places like that which are
subsidized I guess
it's it's a difficult thing for me to
wrap my head around well let me try to
help you for a second I don't think
anybody's going to take you know go for
a subsidy for McDonald's but I do think
that there are uh so public libraries
for instance in New York
um are have been thinking about bringing
in coffee shops um partly it's about
retail but it's not entirely about that
it is about the fact that the way people
like to be now is in that kind of a
space I mean there are studies that show
people are even more effective in their
work if they come to work in a coffee
shop than they do if they work at an
office so part of these this great place
I'm describing in San Francisco are
trying to repli replicate a Starbucks um
so there there is you know I do think
that that is that's a this very um it
there is a possibility of having um some
public spaces
incorporate uh cafes and maybe run them
themselves but I know you're not only
talking about cafes I mean the thing
interesting thing about the place like
McDonald's which I wrote about in Queens
was it was a default public space for a
community of elderly people who didn't
weren't given many other alternatives
um and that is something I think we
don't think about a lot you know think
about neighborhoods who occupies them
and what are the Alternatives of the
people what you know what kind of spaces
are afforded them um and what happened
there was really you know for many of
these people walking to the park a mile
away was
inconceivable so the coffee shop is the
default public space maybe more the
question is in regards to um you
described earlier the difference between
presented public space and adapted
public space
and I don't know I mean to me personally
I have I'm very much interested in
places where blind spots exist whether
it was like that mixed bureaucratic
language that allowed for zuuk or
homemade off ramps right that kind of
blind spot yeah so in the case of that
particular McDonald's maybe those of you
who don't know I I wrote about maybe
some of you about this too there there
was in the um in Flushing Queens where
there's a large um Chinese Community but
an older Korean Community um there was
McDonald's where many elderly Koreans
would congregate and spend all day over
a cup of coffee and the new manager of
that McDonald's told them that they
would have to leave after there is a
sign in all these shops that you would
can stay for 20 minutes but it hadn't
really been enforced he started to kick
them out they would come back back the
police were called in so they were
hauling out these elderly Koreans with
Walkers and um so this became news and
then there was a kind of Dayton worked
out whereby these guys um who were very
sweet but
not uh you you know I mean they knew
what they were doing and I think that I
think that what works out in a lot of
these spaces it happens in P privately
owned public spaces as well like um
these at at the IBM building former I BM
building on 56th Street in Madison these
kind of this is a sort of privately
owned public space so there's an
indoor uh an Atrium where you can sit
and there's a cafe and so forth these
places are um they're more or less
successful depending on the quality of
the manager and their ability to um keep
them places where people can seek Refuge
homeless people um but also places that
don't
become uh homeless Squad communities
it's a very delicate thing and it's it's
done actually on a human level it's not
legisl exactly the legislation allows
people to move people out but the best
places tend to be run with a sense of
just
understanding that's ultimately what the
result is in McDonald's it's supposed to
be in McDonald's I know it's not quite a
direct answer but it it can come down to
this it it no no but it does come down
to this very complicated space is it
public is it private how do you know who
negoti this space um I think McDonald's
has benefited a lot by allowing these
Koreans to come back
in
yeah I'd like to start off with a quick
historical thud and then get to a
question the thud is that luchow was not
on Union Square it was considerably East
and it was right next to the Academy of
Music which was it was the other I'm
sorry what was the restaurant the name
of it wasn't luch house it was the um
sorry there was another German
restaurant that was on Union Square
there forever and ever I don't recall
yeah I me it was this that's right I'm
thank you for that thank you for that
but the question though is that
Architects do learn and Architects are
paid and are often the Agents of people
who build buildings yeah and if
Architects learn and they are the Agents
of people who pay for them don't you
think that the knowledge that's been
gathered about the use of public spaces
in the past
for Gatherings of the sort we've been
talking about which I think are great
don't you think that they would
commission Architects if they do have
public spaces to design them to prevent
these kinds of gatherings in the new
spaces is that an understandable
question well I think that I think that
in the beginning of publicly owned these
kind of plets that were created by the
way I think we need to check on luchow
I'm not quite sure you're right luchow
moved around but in any case
um yeah but hold
on it's okay
um say
what
yeah luchow luchow moved a bit but I
don't want to get bogged down luchow so
um yeah if I can is that future public
spaces designed by Architects for
private right
they
Toes that prevent or make it more
difficult yeah but yeah but the but why
do those public spaces exist they exist
because the people who are developing in
the case of these previous ones people
who are developing these properties were
given bonuses by the public this is a
public gift you are we're saying we're
allowing you to get an exemption from a
zoning Rule and to add square footage to
your building from which you will acrew
Millions of extra dollars in return for
this give something back to the public
fine we give you a plazo so the public
needs then to have some say over the
Quality Maintenance you know use of that
space what no matter what the or you
know the the client uh the the no matter
what the developer says so yes I mean
there's this is about public oversight I
mean I guess I wanted to say in general
that one of the reasons I focus on
public space is I think that for
Architects it's it's just such a ripe
area for um for engagement in a lot of
different kinds of projects which are
quite different than uh just uh you know
taking on commissions for single
buildings I think it's it's an area
that's um that
is right for really interesting design
and for for new models essentially of
Engagement with with the public and with
clients yeah I was just wondering very
very locally if you had any thoughts
about the New Haven green and occupy New
Haven because as as you you well know
yeah technically the green is not owned
by the City of New Haven but by the
ancient Proprietors right and we had an
occupy New Haven and I don't know if
they benefited I I think on some level
they might have benefited I'm sorry I
don't I don't know the answer to this I
think there was an occupation in Harvard
Yard right this was also interesting to
me but I think very few people knew
about it because they the the order was
then closed off the green has the
advantage of also being open how how
busy was the occupation of New Haven oh
it was it it was in intensely busy
um but it was confined to the North and
the West corner of the green so um I
think that's a problem too you know as I
said you need this concentration of St
it but it was not free yeah yeah in the
feeling that yeah but I'm sorry I didn't
see it so I'm reluctant to to
say thanks
thank